there's no other way to say it tsm's
league of legends team is having a bit
of a nightmare at the moment in nine
years of them competing in the lcs this
is their worst ever start to a season
they currently sit at the very bottom of
the table with a one win eight loss
record and there's no real signs of
improvement for some this has been a
great time to meme on the team that once
dominated north america but jokes aside
what the hell is going on with them
honestly guys it's been really good to
see all the interest in these sorts of
league don't have me videos if you are
enjoying them and you haven't subscribed
please do so also like the video as well
it lets us know we're heading in the
right direction thank you so tsm's one
and eight record is their worst ever
start in the lcs in the nine years
they've competed in it some fans might
want to brush this off as a blip but
it's showing no real signs of stopping
now if you're an absolute lcs boomer
like me you'll probably remember tsm's
heyday in league of legends almost six
years ago they genuinely seemed
untouchable domestically doublelift and
bjergsen were the faces of a superstar
roster that achieved an incredible 17-1
record during the 2016 summer split and
2017 saw them win both summer and spring
which begged the question could anyone
domestically compete with them well in
the years since the answer has been
yes
very much so yes team liquid went on to
win the next four splits in a row cloud9
have also grabbed themselves a couple of
wins and hundred thieves won summer last
year to become the fourth orc to take a
title in lcs history but tsm's year
ended with a humiliating world
appearance which saw them booted out in
the group stage with zero wins and six
losses and things got even worse right
after that with both bjergsen and
doublelift announcing their retirement
from pro play bjergsen stepped into the
head coach position for the team while
doublelift moved to streaming then in
2021 tsm owner reggie opened his wallet
up bringing in taiwanese support star
sword art to round out a solid looking
roster that featured veterans power of
evil and huni as well as emerging talent
speaker and last but despite initially
only needing to win a single best of
five to qualify for worlds that year tsm
were eliminated from the lower bracket
by cloud9 so here we are again at the
end of 2021 different offseason same old
story
actually this story is even worse
bjergsen announced he was leaving tsm
after nine years with the org and it was
around this time that doublelift began
to vent his pent-up anger about tsm
specifically their owner reggie i went
and got hot pot with sword art and i
think it was between spring and summer
split it was around msi and the dude was
literally saying that if me and bjergsen
were still playing we would have 100 won
it's like
just unbelievable decisions i don't know
every split i'm on tsm we win and still
like
get treated like that it's just
disgusting
it would be a personal pleasure of mine
to never to see tsm never win anything
again
because of how how
they treated the people who who brought
them everything now we covered the whole
storm that happened after this at the
time some people backed up what
doublelift was saying while some former
players for tsm played down the
accusations or even defended reggie
rumors of reggie's behavior towards his
lcs players particularly had circulated
for years but doublelift's accusations
created a very public conversation about
tsm's environment reggie hit back with a
reddit post in which he dismissed most
of what had been said and suggested that
doublelift was just upset that tsm had
chosen not to work with him when they
replaced him with lost some people
thought this whole story might have died
down but in january it stepped up a
whole level there was a massive uproar
about this and then everything seemed to
die down until last week that's when
wyatt shared an article in which riot
games told them via email that quote we
are aware of the allegations made about
the ceo slash owner of tsm as the league
operator we have engaged the law firm of
omelvany and myers llp to conduct an
independent investigation into claims of
misconduct made against the leader of
this team in accordance with standard
league process an investigation by wyatt
spoke to former tsm employees who claim
they have been subjected to mental abuse
by reggie echoing doublelift's comments
now some people speculated that all of
this might be what's affecting the
league team but tsm have found a lot of
success with their other esports teams
recently they became north american apex
and dota 2 champions and completed a
fairytale run at the sixth invitational
to become world champions whatever's
going on here whether it's caused or
made worse by reggie seems to be unique
to their league team at least on the
surface and while the decline has been a
long time in the making it's clearly
gotten worse recently after a big rush
to shuffle for 2022 tsm's general
manager path explained in a reddit ama
that they wanted to return to their
roots of talent and work ethic and that
they were moving away from their
unsuccessful attempts to integrate
established talent based on the success
of up-and-comers like speaker broken
blade and treats one question tsm fans
had about the new roster was about
communication their new young chinese
talent in shenyi and kaiduau spoke
little to no english at the time and of
the other players only speaker spoke any
mandarin at all this quickly earned them
the nickname of teamspeak's mandarin
which for tsm fans was at least a
welcome replacement for talent
suppression machine it was a gamble
hiring foreign talent with little to no
english skills has worked for western
teams in the past huni himself is living
proof of that when he joined fnatic as
tsm season kicked off though it became
very clear that something wasn't working
they lost all four of their opening
games and the players were very open
about where they thought the problems
lay
i feel like it's going to be a
bit of a challenge to adjust since i'm
kind of looking for other players i'm
the only one that can speak both
languages so in game i feel the need to
like always look out for the chinese
players so i think that's going to be
like a big challenge for me at least to
just try to juggle like different things
in-game for now i think the major
problems like first i think
communication issues and secondly we're
not playing as a team like and there's
so many like small mistakes that makes
the game tough to play
and you know just like as a team like
i'll dimension it like they were just
clearly a better team tsm soon announced
that shenyi would be moved to their
academy team and replaced with ursan
again there were a lot of question mark
things going on tsm said yersan speaking
both english and mandarin would help
solve some of the team's communication
issues and that this move would also
give shenyi time to adjust to north
america in general for fans though it
felt like a promising chinese player
have been brought in and almost
immediately benched on february 15 a
since deleted reddit post claimed to
show the transcript of an alleged leaked
phone conversation between sheny and a
former teammate sheny appears to claim
that tsm didn't think his shot calling
was good enough this sentiment was
echoed in a translation the following
day in tsm's discord of alleged comments
he made on stream that the team had poor
comms and that his teammates didn't
trust him enough to shock call recently
speaker said on twitter that this
narrative has gotten out of hand that no
one was against sheny's shot calling and
that his benching was not anything
gameplay related for the past two weeks
all eyes have been on years and
replacing sheny tsm said he would help
solve some of their communication issues
but after just one win and three losses
with this new setup it's clear that this
may be bigger than just one player
that's five zeroing can get like ahead
of notice really easily
this is a really interesting tp
like that's not gonna ah it's the
communication bro
but it's like uh it's like three two
kills but the game feels completely
doomed yeah that's jenny's fault
honestly and on the same day as sheny's
stream comments made the news travis
gafford shared a report that an unnamed
member of the tsm coaching staff had
been released so not a great week for
tsm who have lost a number of key
figures from the org in recent months
bjergsen doublelift path and vp of
esports lena to name but a few lena
who's also doublelift's girlfriend
shared some thoughts in his twitch chat
recently saying that path and i both
wanted to resign sauron that's bjergsen
when that didn't happen i wanted to go
for jensen doublelift vulcan i was told
that's not worth the cost and i left
right after the offseason ended the
current iteration of the roster isn't
what parth wanted he was just doing his
job she also added that tsm thinks the
amount of money you spend into lcs isn't
worth the value they're getting out
that's why they always talk about
expanding to mobile and other regions
and other games when they're asked about
tsm's future pretty bleak stuff so where
does that bombshell leave us well if you
put all of this together and you join up
the dots it looks a bit like this tsm
lost some important people over the past
year most notably their star players of
bjergsen and doublelift but also some
key upper management figures there's an
argument that they didn't do enough to
keep bjergsen and doublelift jerkson has
said that the roster didn't look as good
to him as team liquids and doublelift
well it's pretty clear he wasn't happy
with the team's direction or their owner
and all of this has been going on during
accusations that reggie has bullied his
employees to the point where riots are
now investigating him and all of that
has occurred while tsm have been
experimenting with foreign talent that
don't speak english which lena has said
was not the choice of upper management
with one of the players currently sat in
academy complaining that his team
doesn't trust him that in a massive
nutshell is what's been happening with
tsm and it's difficult to not see this
as intrinsically tied to their worst
ever lcs start to a season last october
ready said on the tsm subreddit that he
would sooner sell his house and car than
see tsm fall off the way clg has since
their glory days well clg currently sit
above them in the lcs table and
comfortably beat them last week which as
you might expect has been pretty funny
for reggie's critics publicly tsm have
said this is a transitional period of
developing talent which might not come
to fruition until later in the year and
sure that might be the case but the
issue that's being raised more these
days is that tsm's problems may lie
deeper than just their players recent
roster gambles and staff changes don't
appear to be working out sure there's
still time to turn things around but do
these problems lie a lot deeper than
what's happening on summoner's rift
i was watching double legs and sneaky
and meteos discussed the other day about
when tsm will be ineligible for playoffs
right because
at the minute they could still make it
into playoffs right but they'd have to
win a lot of games and have to turn
things around now but we could be in a
position a couple of weeks where they're
already eliminated from playoffs
which is crazy you know for that to
happen in
potentially early march
is kind of mad
maybe we'll make a video about that who
knows